All right.
Thank you, gentlemen.
And our final speaker of the
conference is Tommy Hilfiger.
And let me just tell you
a little bit about Tommy.
I've known him for a long time.
Our daughters-- my
daughter, Jessica, is here,
and his daughter Allie
went to school together.
So we go back on
a personal level,
as well as on a business level.
I showed you, yesterday,
in my presentation,
the QR codes that we're doing.
And I used Tommy as
an example of that.
So you've got to know
a little bit about him,
because he talks
about himself and how
he got started in the
business better than I can do.
But he grew up in
Elmira, New York.
And as he said in
the video, actually
was going into
Manhattan, buying jeans,
and sometimes just dressing
them, and sometimes doing
otherwise.
But reselling those jeans to
his friends back in high school.
And that ultimately
turned into a store
that ultimately turned into
a career for Tommy that's
been quite extraordinary.
And he's done an
extraordinary job, I think,
of continuously
reinventing his brand,
but staying true to this
classic American man and woman
who he caters to, and a
children's line as well.
And his brand is sold, now
exclusively, in Macy's stores
and in Tommy Hilfiger
stores, and is
one of the single
best-performing brands
we have in the entire company.
It's a combination
of many things,
but it's really Tommy's
leadership and Tommy's vision
for who this customer is and
what these customers want
to buy from him.
So please welcome our closing
speaker, Tommy Hilfiger.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much, Terry.
Thank you very much.
I'm proud and honored
to be here today.
I was here a few years ago.
But I didn't have
a crowd like this.
So I'm very happy
and excited to talk
about my 25 years in business.
We just celebrated
our 25th anniversary.
And I have a video to show you.
And after the video, I'll be
glad to talk about my career
and answer any questions.
Thank you.
So as Terry said,
I was brought up
in Elmira, New York,
a very small town
in the middle of New York State.
And my dream was to
be a football player.
But while I was 17 years
old, my coach pulled me along
on the sidelines and said, look,
I don't think you should play.
And I said, what do you mean?
And he said, look,
you know, the linemen
average about 200
pounds each, and you
weigh about 100, 110 pounds.
I don't think it's a good idea.
So I decided to step back
and do something else.
So I got a job in a
sporting goods store.
And as I was working in
this sporting goods store,
I was learning about retail.
And at that point
in time, my dream
was to have my own retail store.
But I wanted to sell cool
clothes in my retail store.
So I took my $150 I'd
saved from working
part time in the
sporting shop, and a gas
station in the nighttime,
in the evenings,
and I drove my Volkswagen
Bug to New York City.
I bought 20 pairs
of bell-bottom jeans
from the streets
of New York City,
put them in the
backseat of my car,
drove them to the
school parking lot,
and started selling
bell-bottoms to my friends
and my classmates, who had
never seen bell-bottoms before.
So that really triggered
my initial interest
in opening a jeans shop.
And I opened a jeans
shop when I was
18 called People's Place in
downtown Elmira, in a basement.
I painted it black.
I played rock and roll music.
And all of my
friends from school,
at 3 o'clock in the
afternoon, when the bell rang,
would march to People's Place
and buy clothes from me.
Within a year, I
started expanding,
and I opened another store
on the Cornell campus.
And what I learned
at that point in time
was that my reach was not
just in Elmira, New York,
but it was beyond.
So I always had a dream of
expanding beyond my roots
and expanding beyond just my
hometown of Elmira, New York.
And while I was expanding into
other college towns in New York
State, I realized there was
an international customer
and a fashion
customer who really
liked what I was selling.
But I was really never
satisfied buying merchandise
from manufacturers,
because I always
thought I could do better at
designing the clothes if I
could do it myself.
So one day, I took
a pad and a pen,
and I started sketching
clothes I would want to wear
and clothes I wanted
my customers to wear.
So my relatives and friends
told me I was crazy.
There was no way I could
ever become a designer
or manufacture
clothes, because you
needed to know how
to cut patterns,
and you needed a lot of
money and connections.
And you really wouldn't
be able to do that.
But I hired local seamstresses
to sew jeans for me.
And when they would
sew the genes,
I took them to the
local laundromat,
and I put sticks and stones and
bricks and Clorox and all sorts
of treatments into
the washing machines
and bleached them, distressed
them, made them stone-washed,
made them look used
and old, but very cool.
So although the local laundromat
wouldn't allow me to come back
in after a few
visits, I thought it
was incredible to invent
something different and new
for the consumer.
So I kept designing.
And I kept putting
these ideas on paper.
And during this
time, my parents were
begging me to go to college.
I was fighting with
them like crazy.
And I really just
wanted to be on my own,
in business on my own.
And one day, my
accountant came to me
and basically told
me I was bankrupt.
And I said, well,
what do you mean?
Can't we just take a bank
loan to pay off the debt?
He said, no, no,
no, you've already
borrowed money from this bank.
And you either have to
close or file Chapter 11.
I didn't even know
what Chapter 11 was.
So that was really
my college education.
It was cold water,
a slap in the face.
And it taught me that
I actually should
have gone to school
to learn economics
and to learn all I could learn
about business before going
into business.
But I put the cart
before the horse.
So I had to take a step
backwards to go forward.
I did end up teaching myself
how to read a balance sheet,
and how to understand
the aspects of business,
and what the business end of
the business was all about.
And I started to actually
formulate a small company.
I formulated a company
called Tommy Hill.
And I manufactured clothes
locally and sold them
to Macy's, Bloomingdale's,
the Gap-- at the time,
they bought many
different brands.
And I actually went into
business on my own in 1984.
After some starts and
stops, because I found out
the Tommy Hill name
was registered,
I was fortunate
enough to meet a man
by the name of Mohan
Murjani, who, at the time,
owned Gloria Vanderbilt jeans.
He asked if I would
come to work for him
and develop a Tommy
Hilfiger brand.
And I said, well, you
know, I'd really love to,
but I just took a job
with Calvin Klein.
Calvin Klein had offered me a
job to design their jeanswear.
And I thought I was
floating in heaven.
I couldn't believe
I was actually
asked by Calvin Klein
himself to design his line.
And I had accepted the job.
So this was a Thursday-- I
promised the Calvin Klein
people I would be
on a plane going
to the Orient on the following
Monday-- when Mr. Murjani said,
go into competition
with Calvin Klein.
I will back you.
I have factories.
I'll support you.
And we'll develop
Tommy Hilfiger.
And I said, but you know,
Tommy Hilfiger people
can't even pronounce the name.
And he said, do you think
people can pronounce Yves Saint
Laurent?
And I said, well,
you've got a point.
And he said, look, why
don't you call Calvin,
tell him that you've
accepted another position.
So with a little bit of
coaxing, a lot of excitement,
I ended up calling Calvin
Klein and telling Calvin
that I was going into
competition with him.
And this was in 1985,
after he had been
established for many years.
And he basically laughed, and
then hung up the phone on me.
So we started Tommy Hilfiger.
And when I started
Tommy Hilfiger,
I decided to design
what I wanted to wear,
what I thought was missing
in the marketplace.
And what was missing,
in my opinion,
was a cool, preppy brand.
There was a Brooks Brothers,
and there was a Ralph Lauren,
and there were preppy
brands out there.
But they were very
boring and very staid.
I decided to make
them very cool.
So I redesigned all
of the preppy clothes
I had been brought up wearing--
the button-down shirt,
the chino trouser, the cotton
sweater, a basic khaki golf
jacket.
And I redesigned
them to make them
be more relevant for the time.
I wanted them to be
relaxed, oversized,
fun, colorful, detailed, but
to have a cool edge with them.
And at this point
in time, I actually
put them in a duffel bag
myself, went to Bloomingdale's,
Neiman's, Saks-- all
the department stores--
knocked on the doors,
and I sold my collection
into these stores.
And that is where I met Mr.
Terry Lundgren, when he was--
actually, Terry was at
Bullocks before Neiman's.
But I was out on the
road selling my clothes
to people like Terry,
who were, I think,
kind enough and open
enough to, at least, sample
what I was selling.
And it ended up selling.
The customers ended
up accepting my
look-- my preppy,
all-American, classic look.
So I started to expand it.
And in 1989, Mr. Murjani
came to me and said, look,
I just took the license
for Coca-Cola clothes.
Would you help me design it?
And I said, Coca-Cola clothes?
I mean, that seems
a little weird.
And he said, well,
look, if you really
want me to continue to support
you with Tommy Hilfiger,
I need your help designing
Coca-Cola clothes.
So I went back to
my drawing board.
And I thought, OK, if I were
to wear Coca-Cola clothes, what
would they look like?
And at first, I envisioned a red
T-shirt with a white Coca-Cola
printing.
And I said, no,
that wouldn't work.
So I decided to design great,
cool, American-classic clothes,
and then put the
Coca-Cola label on them.
So we developed
Coca-Cola clothes
in the '80s and early '90s.
And it was an explosive
business right out of the box.
But within two years,
it took a tumble.
And what that taught me
was that trends never last.
And I would have to develop a
real brand, avoiding trends,
but being true to myself.
So I continued to build my
preppy, all-American, classic
look.
I took on some new
partners in the early '90s.
And these partners
were from Ralph Lauren.
A couple of them owned
Ralph Lauren in Europe.
One was and is a
Chinese manufacturer.
And the other was, at
the time, the president
of Gloria Vanderbilt
with Murjani.
So they had some experience.
And we sat around
one day and decided
what to do with the brand.
And they said, Tommy,
what is the real vision?
And I said, I want to
build a global lifestyle
brand with a preppy attitude.
But I wanted to be aspirational,
inspirational, exciting, fun,
style-wise, on point,
fresh, new, and unique.
So we did that.
And we did it over a
period of 20-some years.
And as I said, this
is the 25th year,
so it was 20-some years
since this new partnership.
And we developed a classic,
all-American, preppy, global
lifestyle brand.
Men's wear, women's wear,
children's wear, fragrance,
accessories, neckwear, dress
shirts, shoes, belts, bags.
We developed homewear.
So it was really coming around
to becoming a global lifestyle
brand.
Well, we weren't really
global quite yet.
We had a store in London,
and we had a small selling
office in the middle
of Europe in Amsterdam.
And the selling office
was run by a man
by the name of Fred Gehring,
who is currently our CEO.
Fred's idea was to expand
the brand throughout Europe
to become a luxury,
upscale lifestyle brand.
Slowly but surely, while we're
expanding rapidly in the United
States, opening shops
and department stores,
advertising, marketing through
celebrity, through music,
through all sorts of unique
ways, sponsoring racing teams,
sailing racing, we were
developing nautical clothes
and dressing some of
the America's Cup teams.
We were developing clothes
for Formula One race drivers,
and really touching society,
touching pop culture
and society.
When it was time to launch
our Tommy and Tommy Girl
fragrances, I said, I think
we should attach ourselves
to music.
Because music, when I opened
my People's Place store
in the very beginning,
was my inspiration.
At that time, when I
was 17 and 18 years old,
my friends and I wanted to
look like the rock stars,
wearing bell bottoms.
We had long hair.
We listened to the Beatles, the
Rolling Stones, Jimi Hendrix--
all of that classic rock music.
And the music was
great, but we wanted
to look like the rock stars.
And that really inspired
me to develop my own stores
and go into the
fashion business.
So here we are in the '90s,
developing a new fragrance.
And we said, what can we do to
be unique in our advertising
and marketing?
So I decided to hire
the sons and daughters
of all the iconic rock stars.
We hired Mick Jagger's son and
daughter, Sting's daughter,
Rod Stewart's daughter,
Quincy Jones' daughter,
and we put them all in a
group in an advertisement
for Tommy and Tommy
Girl fragrance.
And our fragrances
took off like crazy.
At that point in time, I thought
it was a good idea to market
through celebrity,
because I thought
that, if the celebrities
wore the clothes,
their fans would also
wear the clothes.
So we started
dressing Lenny Kravitz
and sponsored a Lenny Kravitz
tour, a Sheryl Crow tour.
We used David Bowie and
Iman in our advertising.
We used everyone from the
Rolling Stones in a sponsorship
concert tour to Britney Spears.
And I remember
the day my brother
Andy brought me Britney Spears.
He said, Britney
is a new musician.
She just moved to New York.
And she has a hit coming
out on the radio any day.
And wouldn't it be great to use
her in our jeans advertising?
So we used her in our
Tommy jeans advertising
the day her Baby One More
Time hit went to number one.
We had no idea who
she was at that time.
But we were deciding,
at that point in time,
to market and advertise
through celebrity,
which is done all the time now.
But I think it's
probably something that
is overused today and overdone.
So I'm always looking for
something new and something
different, something unique,
but holding onto the brand
and keeping true to its roots.
Recently, as you
saw in the video,
we developed a family campaign--
an all-American, quirky, fun
family campaign.
And that really
plants us into who
we are, because we
are a family brand.
We're a cool,
American-classic family brand.
And it all happens as a result
of having a great product.
At the end of the day, I believe
you can have the greatest
advertising, the most
amazing logo, the greatest
name, the most marketing
muscle, but if you
don't have the product, you
absolutely have nothing.
So our focus, at
this point in time,
as it was in the
very beginning, is
to offer the consumer amazing
product, amazing value,
affordable, accessible,
inspirational, aspirational.
And that's what
we're really focused
on more than anything else.
Although we are opening
stores all over the world.
We have over 1,000 stores
in the world today.
We just opened a new store on
Fifth Avenue in New York City.
We have a new flagship store
in Paris on the Champs-Elysees.
We're opening a new flagship in
Tokyo, in Rio, in Buenos Aires.
We just opened in
Dublin recently.
We believe having our own
stores is very important.
But we also believe in
having a relationship
and a partnership with a
department store like Macy's is
incredibly important.
Because with this
exclusive arrangement,
we have a true
family partnership,
where we have shops-- men's,
women's, children's-- in all
of the Macy's stores.
And we don't have
to focus on selling
25 or 50 different
customers in the US.
We focus on a
partnership with Macy's.
And our business, as Terry
said, has never been better.
And it continues to grow.
We continue to add new product
lines, new ideas, new marketing
ideas, and continue to evolve
the business into the future.
All of that keeps me very busy.
As a matter of
fact, for me, it's
not like work at
all because it's
so much fun and so exciting.
But in addition to
that, we're, I think,
charity-minded, as
you [? could ?] say.
We're very involved
in youth outreach
programs like the Fresh
Air Fund in New York City.
We built a summer camp for
the underprivileged children.
We've been involved
in helping raise funds
and building the
Martin Luther King Jr.
Memorial in Washington DC.
We're involved with breast
cancer, Evelyn Lauder's quest
to fight breast cancer.
We're involved with MS,
the race to erase MS.
So we're continually
giving back.
Recently, we adopted
a village in Africa
with Millennium Promise.
So we take a certain percentage
of our sales, a certain amount
of our profits,
and we give back,
which we think is
very important,
and something that
we'll continue
to do for at least
the rest of my life.
We believe that having a very
diverse company is important.
We have people from
all walks of life.
the Chinese factory
sewing machine operators
to top-level executives.
And I'm sure many
of you are thinking
of what to do in the future.
This business offers so
much amazing opportunity.
If you just look
at the marketing
area and the social networking,
which we're very involved with,
that spells opportunity.
If you look at
the manufacturing,
that's all about opportunity.
And you look at the leadership
in the executive programs
Macy's and companies like ours
offer, it's really incredible,
and the sky is the limit.
So if you're contemplating
being in this business
at some point in time,
the opportunities
are endless, not to mention
the creative area, which
is probably my favorite.
It is, I would say, a
dream come true to be
able to sit with a design
team, sit with creative people
and come up with new
ideas, execute those ideas,
put them into the
stores, and actually see
people wearing the ideas
or wearing the clothes
or wearing the accessories
on the streets.
There's nothing
better than that.
That's a fulfilling feeling.
And I would only
wish some of you
could experience
that in your lives.
In addition to, I
think, the success
we've had in building a brand
and building a product line,
I would say that it all
revolves around the people
and the quality of the people.
I have an all-star team.
And I really believe I wouldn't
be standing here today, talking
about the greatness of
my company and the growth
and the phenomenal success
we've had worldwide,
if I hadn't been able
to surround myself
with incredible people.
It is really all about a team.
It's not about me.
It is not about Fred
Gehring, the CEO.
But it's about a team.
And within the team,
we have subteams.
We have our marketing team.
We have our design team.
We have our production team.
We have our accessory team.
We have a team just searching
the world for new fabrics.
We have a team just
going out, looking
for buttons in the world.
We have teams on the
ground just doing events.
And we have teams just
working on fashion collections
for the runway.
And we have teams just
working with celebrities.
We have teams looking around
the world in vintage stores
and antique markets
for new ideas.
It's all about these
teams coming together,
bringing, I would say,
all of the ingredients
needed in building a
global lifestyle brand.
So hopefully, I covered
the general idea
of how this company was
formed and how we built it.
The vision for the
future is as exciting
as it's been in the past--
maybe even more exciting,
with being able to talk
directly to the consumer today.
And I would be more
than happy to answer
any questions you may have.
I hope I covered everything.
Probably too much, but I thank
you very much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, Mr. Hilfiger.
Thank you so much for sharing.
My name is [? Saris ?]
[? Angelo. ?] I teach fashion
design and merchandising at
a high school here in Tucson.
And last March, I had a
chance to take 35 of my girls
to New York.
And we actually
toured Tommy Hilfiger.
And I had a chance to
meet your sister, Betsy.
And she was amazing--
very, very personable.
And I think all of my girls
were amazed with all that you're
doing for the community.
One thing I just
wanted to ask is
what you see the next 25
years for Tommy Hilfiger,
and what you're hoping
to do with the company.
Well, for the next
25 years, I think
I can say that the
number one priority is
to improve the product.
Always improve the product.
I think there are
better ways to sew
in the pocketing
in our jeanswear.
I think there are better
ways to soften the fabric.
I think there are organic
opportunities, sustainable
opportunities.
You just heard the gentleman
speak on organic cottons.
I really believe a lot
of that is our future.
But the first and
number one priority
is all about the product.
And then the evolution
of the brand,
of marketing-- the evolution
of our own retail stores,
and more of our
own retail stores.
I really believe that
everything we're doing today
can be done better tomorrow.
So it's about challenging
ourselves to be
better at everything we do.
Hi, Tommy.
Hi.
I remember the fad well
of the Coca-Cola shirts.
I had one and loved it.
And I've loved your
brand for a long time.
I used to be a buyer at
a sporting goods store.
And I noticed
lately, or recently,
that you redesigned some
professional sports uniforms.
And they've turned
out very cool.
And I have two
questions for you.
Do you plan to do any more
designing of professional sport
uniforms?
And secondly, in our
lifetime, will we
ever see baseball uniforms
become more flattering?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I can say designing sports
uniforms is a big challenge.
Because the technical
aspect that goes into it is,
I would say,
challenging at best.
But I would love to design
more sports uniforms.
But unfortunately, I have to
design for my favorite teams,
and that becomes a
little conflicting.
I did a number of
different designs for ESPN
as examples of what I would
do if I were to design clothes
for the Cowboys, the Lakers,
and a number of different teams.
But I started working as a stock
boy in a sporting goods store.
And I learned a lot.
But ultimately, it's
all about the product.
Thank you.
Hey, Tommy.
Hi.
Tom Julian over here.
Nice to see you.
How are you?
Well, thank you.
Hey, Tommy.
So you know, you've never
done a secondary line.
You've never
bastardized your name.
You've always kept
this new luxury going
with your entire collection.
That's hard for a lot of
companies and brands today.
So how do you maintain it?
Or what is always your criteria
for being aspirational,
quality, and so image-oriented?
I think it's a
very good question.
Actually, in the mid-'90s,
I made a big mistake.
We overexpanded.
And we created more supply
than there was demand.
As a result of that, we
had to take a big step
backwards to go forward.
And that taught us a lesson.
And the lesson was that to
keep it somewhat exclusive
is important-- to somehow
be on the other side
of the supply-demand equation.
Because once you
oversupply the demand,
you have a glut of product
in the marketplace,
and the customer says, no more.
So it is, I think,
always a challenge.
It's something we're
looking at every single day.
But I really believe
that there is
such a thing as overexpanding
and damaging the brand.
We really experienced,
I would say,
a brush with it in the '90s.
Fortunately, our management
team acted upon it very quickly.
We cleaned up
distribution, so to speak.
We were selling all of
our excess to discounters.
And we put an end to that.
And we do have some of
our own outlet stores.
But we are always
looking at the balance,
and always making sure that we
don't overexpand and over-flood
the market with our
product, because it takes
the value out of the product.
Perfect.
And then how would you
describe new luxury today?
What is new luxury
for the consumer?
New luxury today, for me and
for the consumer, I believe,
is affordable luxury.
Because people want
luxury, but people
want to be able to afford it.
And in years past, luxury
was something that you really
couldn't quite afford.
It was always a tremendous
reach to buy something cashmere
or something from one
of the luxury brands.
But I think it's
up to us to offer
that customer great luxury
at affordable price points.
Because everyone
wants it, and everyone
feels that they're
deserving of it somehow.
And whether it's a
cashmere cotton sweater,
or whether it is a
handbag with a bit of trim
from either a lizard or snake
or fur, just to, I would say,
make the customer
feel that they're
getting something luxurious.
I think that's very
important to do.
I know Macy's is
working on that.
My friend, Michael Kors,
is one of the number
one designers in America today.
But he has a big presence
in Macy's, along with Coach,
selling luxury handbags,
accessories, shoes,
and fashion.
And I really believe that
they're leading the way.
I like being on that bandwagon.
I think it's very important.
Thank you.
Hi, Tommy.
Hi.
Going back to that point in your
life, when your accountant came
to you and said that you're
going to go bankrupt,
what did you say
to yourself to be
able to still feel that you
could persevere and continue
with your dream?
Do you want to know
what I said at first?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
See, my father was a
watchmaker, jeweler.
My mother was a nurse.
And we had nine children.
So that sort of tells
you that I couldn't
go knocking on my parents'
door to get a loan.
I really had to rethink my life.
And I had to decide
at that point in time,
should I go back to school?
Should I continue on?
I was so passionate
about what I was doing.
I decided to continue on.
And I learned about the law.
I learned about the fact that,
if you are Chapter 11, which
is a form of bankruptcy, you can
stay in business as long as you
pay your creditors off,
and as long as you really
operate on a cash basis.
So I kept in
business at the time,
and then built the business
back up to the point
where I could sell
it, take that money,
and become my own manufacturing
designer brand, which
was tiny at the time, but
I had visions and dreams
of it growing.
And my dreams did come true.
So I do believe
dreams do come true.
All right.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
I appreciate you sharing your
transparency and being real.
I know a lot of us students
at the University of Arizona
have dreams.
And you've shown us that
they are obtainable.
So thank you.
But mine is more or less just a
comment that I wanted to make.
On behalf of all of
the students attending
the Global Retail
Conference, we want
to say thank you for
all of you for allowing
us to be a fly on the wall.
We take away great insight
on brand development,
building brand equity,
and most importantly,
understanding the
forever-changing environment
and challenges
faced by retailers.
And for that, we want
to say thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's a great compliment.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Tommy, what are the
contemporary trends
in American casual
wear and denim,
and how are they different
around the globe?
What are other cultures' tastes?
Well, I think they vary
somewhat around the globe.
Not tremendously, because
the people in Japan
are wearing the same
styles that they're
wearing in Paris, that they're
wearing in Minneapolis.
But I really believe that there
are nuances in different areas.
The preppy look in some
areas is not the same
as it is in the states.
In Italy, it's much brighter
and much more slender.
In France, it's a
little bit more staid
and a little bit more starched.
I think that it
depends on the region.
And it depends on even
the weights of the fabric.
Our business in Germany is much
different than our business
in Spain.
The Germans like
heavier, darker fabrics.
The customer in
Spain would prefer
something lighter and brighter.
So we mold and shape
to the territory.
And we do that with My Macy's.
Terry developed a program
called My Macy's, whereby,
in Texas, the stores might
want something different
than they would want in Boston.
And I think that's
really a great way
to plan and develop a
business, because you're really
responding to the
customers' needs.
But from a fashion
standpoint, I think
we're all on the same track
of what is fashionable,
what is now.
But I think, from
a fit standpoint,
a color, a fabric
standpoint, it does vary.
And it's a good question.
Yes.
I work for a brand design firm.
And I just wanted to say,
first of all, that I love
your American-- I'm over here.
Right over here.
All right.
OK.
The speaker is over here, so--
I'm sorry.
I love your American
Family campaign.
I think it's fantastic.
Thank you.
One of the best things
about it and, I think,
about your brand-- its essence
is the styling of the clothes,
not just the clothes themselves.
I'm wondering how you make sure
that that reaches the store
level, and that the styling
itself is translating.
That's a very difficult
proposition, making sure
that the stores look
like the advertising.
Well, we're talking about
hundreds and hundreds
of designs every season.
And it's up to the buyer and
the buyers in these stores
to select.
And sometimes,
they may not think
that one of the
jackets in the ad
would be appropriate for their
consumer because of the climate
or whatever.
But we try our best
to make sure that what
we show in the advertising
ends up on the selling floor.
And sometimes, it ends up on
the selling floor in smaller
quantities and sells
out immediately,
which prompts us to redesign
the same item with, maybe,
a nuance or two for
the next season.
But we try very
hard to make sure
that whatever is in the
advertising shows up
in the stores.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.